When you think about how you experience technology today, it's like behind this glass screen.
And you're kind of stuck.
It feels cold.
We've unlocked the screen.
Really what we're trying to do is break down the walls between technology and people.
It's basically a see-through display that you wear.
And it lets you see holograms in your world, in your space all around you.
The ability to draw with your hand or to take an asset, an image and move it or scale it.
It's a very natural way of interacting with it.
Here's what you can do with holographic video.
Here's what you can do with using your world as a game level.
Here's what you can do with taking the power of 3D modeling and creation.
And guess what?
Point it out of the screen into real 3D, and then sharing what you've created with others.